[Music]  baby brother  you got a pig aside I want a lawyer  you and I both know those days are gone  you have a choice to make work for me or  line up like your father we don't have  much time they're protecting us from  anarchy tell our friends down below they  got our full operational support  harmony peace it's a lie they gonna take  everything what do you want me to do  known as we fight back we got a chance  based on a full-blown insurgency known  as Phoenix  the networks communicate don't clean it  something big major blow the team goes  tonight you ready no one gets taken  alive hello Gabriel you have a job to do  I've got to play I have faith in you  light a match  ignite a wall I can take the risk get  back to the way that things used to be  it's like I said those days are gone  [Music]  you